I think that just about covers it as
an introduction to generalization,
so I think maybe it's a good time
to reflect on what we've learned.
>> I'm willing to do that,
especially if it means I don't
have to do another quiz.
>> Okay, well, but I, eh, okay, no,
I'm not going to do another quiz, but
I am going to ask you what we learned.
>> Okay, I think I can remember some
of that, so I think the big thing we
learned is that there is both a need for
and a way to do generalization.
>> In reinforcement learning, yeah.
>> And the need part comes
from the fact that for
a lot of problems we care about, there
are zillions and zillions of states.
>> You could be our
generation's Carl Sagan.
>> Yes, zillion and zillions of states.
And that's a problem because of course,
we'll visit states that we've never seen
before, and the chances of seeing every
state an infinite number of times and
all that other stuff that the theory
requires is just kind of unreasonable.
Or at least slow, and so
it would be nice to overcome that.
>> Good, okay, and methods for?
>> We talked about a few methods, but
I think at the end of the day, it really
boiled down to let's just take all
that stuff we learned in
supervised learning and apply it.
>> Cool, but
we did talk about some specific ones.
Do you remember any particular
supervised learning methods that we
looked at in the context
of generalization in
reinforcement learning?
>> Sure, we looked at linear
function approximation,
which makes sense because linear
is nice and well behaved.
Or at least we hoped it was.
And it does seem like the simplest most
straightforward thing to
do based on what we know.
But I think it's worth mentioning
that we were function approximating
something in particular, right?
So we were deciding to do the value
functions and to try to learn those.
That's how we were doing
our generalization.
>> Right, that's a good point.
We actually looked at different
functions that we might approximate,
value functions,
policies and models, and
we focused primarily on value functions.
Models, there's interesting
things to say about that, but
it's not nearly as well studied or
as well understood.
The value function case, we just focused
on representing like the V function or
the Q function, and
that could be done in a number of ways.
And we looked at kind of
a general gradient form,
where we turned the Bellman equation
itself into a kind of an error measure.
And then we looked specifically at
linear value function approximation,
how you could, if you have a set of
features, you can map them to values
using a linear function and
how we might learn that linear function.
>> Right, and that's pretty much what
has been almost done from the start.
I don't think we did hardly anything
with the policy function approximation.
>> Nope, and that's okay.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And
one of the reasons it's okay is because
you're able to talk about lots of
successes that people have had
doing function approximation
with value functions.
>> Yeah, and there are some successes
on doing function approximation with
policies as well.
In fact a lot of the coolest stuff in
robotics in the reinforcement learning
setting has happened where there's
an actual gradient taken with respect to
representation of the policy.
It's not exactly clear why it seems
to be the more effective way to use
feedback in the robotic setting,
but it's worth noting at least that
policy gradient methods do seem to
work well in the robotics setting.
>> That's a good point, but
it doesn't really matter.
It's not like robotics is the future or
anything.
>> Robotics is totally the future.
>> Mm, we'll see.
We'll have this conversation in 2050 and
see what we think.
>> In 2015, it is 2015.
>> No, 2050.
>> 2050, phew.
I'm like, my gosh, it's the future and
I wasn't even paying attention.
>> [LAUGH] Well that's okay.
I, for one,
welcome our new robotic overlords.
>> Good.
>> In the meantime,
we had all these successes,
and you named a few.
Right, the one I remember
the most was TD gammon, but
there were others, which if I went back
and looked at what we've recorded,
I'm sure I could find
out what they were.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or maybe you'll just remember.
>> Well, I mentioned several, but
Atari is one that actually came up
relatively recently, and
hopefully will actually change
the way people think about this whole
topic of generalization, but we'll see.
It's still too new to know.
>> Very good, prince.
Okay, so now those successes
of course were followed by
the downer of problems and
sort of problem cases,
where things that seem like they would
obviously work do not obviously and
easily work, even in the case
of linear function of arguments.
>> Yes, that's exactly right.
The good news is in the last few years,
there's a new set of methods that
are based on TD and a gradient.
But it's a different kind of
gradient that actually uses
the function approximator as part of the
error metric that's being resolved and
that these can actually
these provably converge.
For the case of linear, in particular,
the paper that talks about GTD2 actually
shows what happens when you apply this
particular problem case, the Baird
counter example that we looked at.
And you can actually correctly learn
it if you use this other update rule
instead of kind of the classic Bellman
residual minimization kind of thing.